i just aimed here
then it's bone against bone
this bone
so as i come it's like a flash i do that
so that's subtle in itself what i need
is what i need is his arm to be in
what's known as the unbendable arm
position
now
i can move him with one unit
if i'm going to do the hand version
there's two ways of doing it one is with
the thumb
where you keep it rotating out
and keep rotating this down down
it saves you putting power on here
i need this
don't let it come back i go to that
this thumb
goes down
[Applause]
and it's at right angles to his body
never try to move up there because what
happens is
oh
this is what happens
so there's no value since you used to
say just put it at right angles and
press
arm
then what happens is
i cut
down
the angle of his hand
cut down the angle of his hand
i don't go in
and go past it and now try to take it or
as he blocks me out
i come up to here
i go to the angle of his hand
and now it cuts
down
[Applause]
perhaps this is why nearly 50 years i've
been doing i could still enjoy it
because
but there's so much to
to know when you get saying you know
i've added
the understanding of ikyo
the motel
here
to turn into nikki oh the fingers
just go to his head that makes the arm
so it's more direct now so now i've
pulled the shoulder down into
the mat
because he has stiff shoulders
i won't be hard but go around here
and apply the
technique
the lightning
okay so we've got
normal ikea
[Applause]
angles
see he won't keep moving around if you
if you just put the right angles put
pressure on there as you come up
somebody more younger than my agile will
do better
keep this going away from you
this is the yukio goes down not into his
head
same thing
but
now this will tip to his head
make the arm a little more upright
[Music]
he'll come around don't worry about him
tapping
[Music]
essentially
same thing
here
focus
okay so
you can do them all in
and all this is being done fast but
they've all been done
at the right time
they're all being
very sensitivity it's uh
you know we're going now
and you've done it so many times that
you know where each piece fits
you just keep falling with the tents
[Applause]
just
okay